and I thought that Delia did a good job
last time you know and um I also loved
Esther she's been texting me do my show
I might do her show and listen this
podcast right now I love it it's my life
it is it's my life I go to the [ __ ] I
was in Houston and all these kids come
up and then where's kalila you know
where's Guilbeau was George has a pink
dick you know I swear to God do people
say all the time face people yell it
from the crowd George has a big dick and
then I had to explain to the people that
don't know oh this producers really
paying I think it's had the opposite
effect on me like Gilbert he goes out
and like he gets recognized and he'd
like it's it's kind of a cool thing for
me like many sends videos of like Tiger
belly fat they love you guys
they love you too what do you they
really do okay and I know you told me
you tried to pull me out of the house
yes I tried to get her to go out
something's happened to me in the last
year that like I find myself to be
unrecognizable from who I used to be in
Gilbert last over the weekend was like
kalila like put your come on let's go
out and I don't know how to be outside
anymore
like I've become like a [ __ ] recluse
I turned it I turned her into me it this
is serious no don't give yourself that
much credit I'm not giving you any
credit yeah you didn't sway me to become
a recluse oh no no anxiety because I
haven't seen the Sun in three years well
you saw it a couple days ago open the
black hole something is going on I think
that I need but there is influence you
know that is it little influence yeah I
miss you the way I behaved because if I
don't sleep at 5:00 a.m. I'll never see
you we won't have a relationship if I go
about being the person that I used to be
which was you know somebody who got up
at a reasonable time in the morning
let's say 9:00 a.m. and I go to bed
let's say at 1:00 a.m. right if I do
that and if I live by those hours we
won't be in a relationship you need
someone nocturnal like you and that's
your sacrifice thank you or the ship to
me to the half dark yeah what's HAP
sacrifice thank you I'm living this like
a graveyard hour and they think it's
caused me a lot of but you have to miss
arrest and like anxiety and depression
and I think that's the reason why I
don't want to go out and be you saved
had balls I do I go out a hike a lot but
doesn't I don't want to be where people
are like if you tell me to go hike
Runyon Canyon I'm like nope because
they're gonna be people there I go to
the [ __ ] back hills over here and
rescue tadpoles that's what I do
you're cool yeah we have a 15 tadpoles
looks really excited about
we had no I he's actually pretty excited
about it he's never seen frogs on morph
cuz they're you know they he and I think
that if you've never seen him more feels
worth you know kind of yo dude you know
I've been watching planet Earth part too
you know and let me say something right
now man I get I get invigorated by [ __ ]
like that you know the birds-of-paradise
the way they clear they clear out you
know the clear little clearing yeah
right right and to call the bay right
and then like the mate the women will go
on a stick to look down and the birds of
prey will go check it out and they'll
show their chest but it's a it's a
beautiful color yeah and then the girl
the lady um Burgos yeah and this will
fly away I mean but no but my point is
is that they - you know I mean have to
hit on chicks yeah do all that stuff and
I did not know that and some of them
have to work way harder like some birds
have to make nests that are attractive
to the female birds yeah so they make
different types like each birds gonna
have different architectural style and
they're going to adorn it with flowers
and bright things to attract the mate
and if the mate comes in like no I don't
like your house she'll go and find
somebody else with like a bigger better
house so gold diggers are also in the
bird species I guess and then you look
you learn about sloths on the island
they swim this will find their mate yes
so slow they can't even though they're
pretty good swimmers and I thought I
thought when I was watching it if like
if like I suppose
like animal rape mm-hmm like was a thing
yeah there's probably six guys in the
world that do that Ducks rape nobody at
human beings Oh
if human beings like I like raping
animals what do you mean you can't get
away can't get away
oh I think that when I watch stuff like
that why that's not a good frame of mind
to be in I know I have other thoughts
like oh look at the way they swing he
goes back to but I go back to life oh
yeah yeah because as soon as they hit
the ground it's like 50 guys gangbang
yeah we're gonna call from PETA no I
don't care I don't give a [ __ ] about Ava
[Music]